since 2014 a working group has been
developing proposals for the
rehabilitation of the Calliope river
today we're on the riverbank office of
the Kuiper beres school this is the nice
part of the type where every level and
what's happening here what are the
council turning on doing what we intend
to do is some is try and just make plan
what used to be here as you can see in
the background just over here it used to
be quite full of repo and oxygen we'd
with them this whole area right
throughout the river and that's depleted
and we're not sure why there's many
theories there's some there's nose
around Salt weeds there's those around
changing conditions since the earthquake
we need to know what the effect of
sediment and how deepen all of those
things we need to know the effects of of
what's happened with the nitrates in the
river and all of those things that the
water zone committees concentrating on
the moment a lot of locals of theories
around sprays so we need the information
on whether they're making any difference
all of that sort of science has been
collected as well as having monitors in
here to see how much salt as being
pushed back whether the river flows from
the Y Mac in here are too low or whether
indeed they run they're not affecting us
at all you've mentioned sediment hair
exactly are you going to deal with it
how are you going to analyze it so what
we want to do is dig this out all the
see them and be out of here and then put
the channels through the river so that
the water can flow on the channel and
this will collect the sediment and the
cost of actually recruiting the river
will be a lot different to what it used
to be because you'll be able to
hopefully take the sediment from one
place as opposed to write the way down
and around the river
and we want to collect information from
the public about what would be good
areas and what what what's their view on
this stuff as well not just the science
around it but what are they thinking as
well where these cinnamon threats and
things should be like every River in New
Zealand there's no easy fix lots of
skips lots and lots of steps to
rehabilitate and make sure that we can
get things back to well the way they
were I'm not sure whether you can get
them back the way they were but as close
as we can get to what we had if not
better
[Music]
so happen people have these safe all
right here they can come and there'll be
an open day at the Royal califo and
people can have their input that way we
have the website we have counselors
community board members and we really
want people to have their input there
are six proposals we'd like your
feedback on the 10-year open day on the
twenty-seventh of april or find out more
at why Michael Eddie govt TMZ
you